fuir le tumulte de la ville certains y
songer bien avant la crise sanitaire et
les destinations pouvait être assez
originale la lune c'est être après je
préfère partir d'un marché possible en
1957 cet homme avait beaucoup d'espoir
quitter son jardin pour aller vivre sur
mars
j'espère qu'il ya des êtres humains et
vivent dans ces lieux avec beaucoup
d'intelligence que la planète de la
terre en 1965 cet autre monsieur
sabotier de profession se passer bien
des hommes dans sa forêt bretonne son
mode de vie atypique lui balaie un
reportage diffusé sur la première chaîne
de lower tm monsieur le moal vous vivez
depuis 82 ans dans la forêt depuis 82
ans vous faites des sabots vous devez
être le seul le dernier sabotier à vivre
dans la forêt vivre seule dans la forêt
être coupé du monde moderne c'était
aussi le choix de cette sculptrice en
1996 une quête de nature et de silences
raconté dans ce reportage de france 3
j'ai réussi à créer ici je crois un lots
de deux différences je peux vivre à mon
rythme où je peux vivre au rythme à mon
rythme et en vidant pour rythme des
saisons au rythme du temps qui passe
parmi les lieux très recherchés pour
vivre en parfaite solitude l'île déserte
en 1965 au coeur de l'archipel des
écrits ou ce robinson de la manche seul
et c'est difficilement approcher surtout
lorsqu'il s'agissait d'une équipe de
télévision
nous avons dû attendre pendant quatre
heures avant de pouvoir lui parler mais
au bout de 4h apprivoiser il a bien
voulu se laisser filmer autrement quand
elle est objective est loi depuis
combien de temps êtes vous sûr c'est et
les mois d'avril et vous ne vous êtes
pas ennuyé depuis
non autre alternative pour fuir le
vacarme du monde prendre le large
littéralement la mer c'était le refuge
du navigateur bernard moitessier sa
seule issue pour quitter la société
moderne où il est en train de craquer
les gens viennent de plus en plus fous
ils seront par contre on est dirigé par
des plans des gens qui sont mon monde à
moi ça les fera la société moderne
ça n'est pas cette société de
consommation ça ne marche pas je ne
marcherait jamais pour ce truc là la mer
la forêt l'espace les destinations sont
multiples pour fuir le tumulte des
villes et vous quelle est la vôtre
[Musique]